almost seven months into joe biden's
presidency and the border remains an
utter disaster video shows more illegal
immigrants crammed into a room amid
rising coveted fears and we're just
getting staggering new numbers agents
apprehended 212 000 migrants just during
the month of july breaking yet another
20-year record to put things in
perspective the numbers have gone up
every single month since president biden
was sworn in homeland security secretary
aleandro mayorkas was down at the border
today trying to downplay the situation
the situation at the border is one of
the toughest challenges we face we have
seen
my surges in migration before
we've seen them in the past
and migration
surges are not new
and while biden officials try to claim
there isn't a crisis take a look at this
texas judge who deals with the situation
first hand
we are all very very frustrated because
what people don't understand this is not
just a border crisis we keep calling it
a border crisis but in all reality it's
a national crisis president biden has
really failed the american people and
failing us there in the border we are
basically battling a war against these
refugees that are coming out coming
illegally with our hands behind our back
tied with our hands behind our back not
understanding not having the resource to
be able to do this
greg the floor is yours oh well thank
you you're welcome what should i do with
it
really dirty i think you should people
i know it is absolutely awful that's the
problem with outnumber they leave it a
mess never should have leased it out
terrible people
so this i think this spectacle is the
best education for the viewer to see how
corporate media actually works you ask
yourself why do these photos not matter
why why does the suffering not matter
because the media's team is in power and
the corporate media has turned every
facet of life into a team sport whether
it's the border whether it's covet or
law enforcement they find out what side
they're against and they just pick the
other side they pick the other side so
that's what's happening here so it tells
you that under trump the concern about
kids in cages was mere kabuki theater it
was just false outrage because on behalf
of their team who are out of power the
dems so you you can contrast the
dramatic changes in behavior outrage
under trump ambivalence under biden so
what that tells you is it's not about
immigrants it's about our disgusting
dirtbag media because life doesn't
matter to them politics does their
politics does that they don't care about
these people to make it more infuriating
compare the media's demonic mockery
of unmasked americans versus again
complete ambivalence towards uh illegals
streaming in who may have coveted or do
have covet covid so that begs a question
is kovit really that bad
if the democrats are fine letting in
people who have it of course it is it's
bad but they just possess the
consistency of a crackhead
so there you go
i'm
i'm just thinking about that consistency
of a crackhead totally great brian
understands right yeah yeah brian too
well
so if if you look at the poll numbers uh
biden has a 35 percent approval on
immigration 57
disapprove martha so if anything the
white house has always been tethered to
the poll numbers and so maybe this is
the best chance for the country to have
some semblance of order at the border
because they're most likely to react to
not the suffering
not the uh the children being put at
risk not the incoming the fentanyl
coming across the border but oh it hurts
them in the white house because people
are upset with their policy yeah i'm
glad you brought up the polls there's
another poll that's also really
interesting to look at which is the
independent voters broken down in those
numbers and president trump had approval
on immigration issues among independent
voters at 39 percent
which is pretty high actually given the
politics and the controversy over that
biden is at 31 with independence those
are the voters that are going to be
looking at these issues when it comes
time in 2022 uh and it's been a really
rough week uh for the biden white house
there's no doubt about it i know we're
going to talk about afghanistan in a
moment um but when you look at inflation
you look at the rise of coveted with the
delta variant you look at what's going
on at the border there have you know
there's a bit of whack-a-mole going on
um in terms of how to manage these
crises and and when i listened to the
homeland security uh head down at the
border you know it's almost like it's
like a baghdad bob situation i mean you
look at what he's saying and they're
speaking past each other in terms of the
two narratives on this um he's saying
the border's closed right and then he's
saying well the problem is that which
obviously it isn't he says in the next
sentence 212 000 people came across the
border in july so it's quite obvious
that the border is not closed i mean
it's very clear to americans except that
as uh greg rightfully points out it's
not being covered in too many places
except uh here and others but then he
also talks about how the trump
administration dismantled and
destabilized the whole system at the
border and what he's really referring to
there is a question of how they dealt
with unaccompanied minors and we all
know the history on that and kids in
cages it was very difficult um
period in the trump administration but
the fact that you know so now they have
to rebuild it he's saying oh they broke
the whole system apart so now we have to
rebuild it we're letting in all these
unaccompanied minors um the question of
whether or not that's a more humane way
to deal with these children to sort of
force them to be separated from their
parents so that they can be brought
across the border um i i think it's just
a very very tough argument to make so i
think a lot of people at home go they're
scratching their head obviously the
border's open hundreds of thousand
people pouring across it and this is
becoming an increasingly difficult
political
situation for the administration uh
where is kamal harris austin she's in
charter charge of the border crisis and
clearly she's doing a blockbuster of a
job well they you know look they they
had
stumbles of presentation uh for the vice
president for sure uh she
seems to have tried to back away from
that issue somewhat i think
the
one thing about the surge
is that this is comparing to the year of
the pandemic
if you actually compare to a normal year
this surge is not out of the ordinary
there's an article in the texas tribune
that showed that at the same point this
year when there were 419 000
uh
illegally
people illegally coming across the
border in 2019 it was 450 000
so it is comparable to that the
achievement of the trump administration
was not reducing illegal immigration
into the united states it was reducing
legal immigration they cut legal
immigrants student visas and others by
more than 60 percent and i would argue
that's a mistake i think that was not
the way to go about it i would love to
have to get to the point where we could
uh talk about that talk about reforming
immigration but we can't without border
security 1.3 million people have already
caught come year to date across the
border 19 000 kids and because you left
the first thousand in and said you can
stay you got 18 000 more people selling
their house or their mud head to their
lean to in order to get their child to
put with a stranger to go thousands of
miles through dangerous situations to
try to get to our country and hope for
the best instead they stay in a military
base or they go in a tent with over
other coveted victims there's no winners
here maorkus knows better tom homan says
mayorkus knows the issues and i believe
that he's the fall guy for this the vice
president won't step up can you imagine
the vice president says kind of step
back it's like oh greg we need you to
host the five and he goes i'm gonna kind
of step back no your seat would be empty
that's not an option brian is trying to
take over here right here's what this is
guys when i started talking there was a
minute left what i'm trying to say is
this is a this is unmitigated disaster
it was totally preventable and for joe
biden to be in delaware and uh hiding
out on vacation with afghanistan falling
apart and this border coming to pieces
in the middle of a pandemic is
inexcusable i have one question for you
greg gutfeld who are the 35 percent of
the people polled who think that the
immigration and the border crisis is
okay who approve of it who are those
people
i don't know who they are but i think
that in every poll there's between 25
35
idiots
that's what they are okay crackhead
idiot yes no that's brian well thank you
uh but by the way uh a lot of people
don't think we shouldn't have a border
it's not right for us to have a border
you know that's been that's been there
no ice no homeland security no
protection the squad great so they can
talk to the people who have lost
relatives to drug overdoses and fentanyl
overdoses just in the last year up 30
percent in 2020 talk to those people
suffering or talk to you know anybody
who is uh
who is hammered and damaged by the human
trafficking and drug trafficking hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else